today House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
announced a formal impeachment inquiry
into President Trump over his
inappropriate conduct with Ukraine
they think it's happening yeah yeah
Trump was furious and said this is nuts
I've done way worse things I've killed
people what are you talking about it's
almost not even a joke no no I know
let's just say he's wounded people uh
this all started when a whistleblower
lodged a complaint over Trump's phone
call with the leader of Ukraine we don't
know who the whistleblower is yet but we
do know they'll end up on Dancing with
the Stars thinking about it right makes
it all worth it early this morning at
the United Nations president Trump
railed against illegal immigration yeah
yeah there was an awkward moment when
Trump said to the UN delegates look
around how did you people even get in
here
that's true story to me
president Trump's adult children
including Tiffany watched their dad's
speech at the UN today yeah
afterwards Ivanka Don jr. and Eric said
hey Dad great speech and Tiffany said
hey Dad I'm Tiffany you really showed
Tiffany when the impeachment
announcement broke today as you can
imagine it was sort of interesting to
see how some of the left-leaning
television news personalities covered it
for example check out this clip of
Rachel Maddow if you watch very
carefully you can see she's having a
hard time containing her excitement over
the news of Trump's possible impeachment
proceed with their investigations under
that umbrella of impeachment inquiry the
president must be held accountable no
one is above the law what a time to be
alive
[Music]
[Applause]
Rachel Maddow blew up yes and she's
filled with confetti he's filled with
confetti yeah as we always knew - pinata
news well yeah exactly